[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and just when i thought my intros
couldn't get any worse after three years
and a whole pandemic later the first
volume of season four has arrived and
along with it my life for the past few
days this video isn't a recap i'll be
covering some of the show's biggest
questions and i've left timestamps below
so you can see all the topics i'll be
covering and get ready because every
time there's a product placement you
have to drink
[Music]
honeycomb mountain dew pringles and
apple jack's minute made you butter too
crayola and others too many to mention
or else i'll get copyright sued
the name of season four's big bad wechna
is actually an anagram for vance the
surname of fantasy author jack vance who
inspired the magic system used in
dungeons and dragons in the d d universe
vechna is a once human king that
ascended to godhood and has gone by
various titles like master of the spider
throne and the maimed lord which after
watching season 4 really begins to make
sense for the first part of the season
it seems vecna has seemingly come out of
nowhere attacking various hawkins teens
shortly after 11 has left town to start
a new life in lenora hills california
but as our beloved dusty buns theorizes
vecna has actually been in hawkins the
whole time it was always thought that
the mind flayer was the supreme ruler of
the upside down but in fact it was
merely a foot soldier of vecna but that
begs the question why now why didn't
vecna reveal himself way back in season
one the answer is twofold one vecna
wasn't always this powerful in fact
during his transition from human to
undead he was in a weakened state he
needed victims to get stronger as dr
samuel owen says in episode 3 each time
it returns it comes back stronger
smarter
deadlier the second reason centers
around 11. at the end of season 3 she
lost her powers making it the perfect
time for vecna to unleash his master
plan to take over the world by creating
hundreds if not thousands of gates
between our world and the upside down
eventually taking it over and reshaping
it in his image with the only person who
could take him on powerless and out of
town it was the perfect time for him to
reveal himself eleven's loss of powers
is explained rather quickly by dr
brenner who states that when oxygen was
cut off from her brain it rewired it in
such a way that made her forget how to
use it kind of like when someone suffers
a stroke they may forget how to walk but
vechna's origins go back even further to
1947 with the birth of henry creel henry
was born with supernatural powers
chiefly the ability to venture into
one's mind and see them for who they
truly are this applied to his parents
victor and virginia creel who on the
outside looked like the quintessential
loving parents but also held traumatic
pass we don't know much about virginia
but victor ordered the shelling of a
building during world war ii which
killed a baby perhaps even more which is
why we see him tormented by the image of
a cradle burning in a fireplace it was
this ability to see into people's minds
that fueled in him a hatred for humanity
who he believed to be the ultimate pest
to him humanity was a bringer of chaos
throwing the balance of the world off
kilter while it may seem like we have
some sort of form of structure in our
society it's all a facade to him
humanity merely marches to its own death
acting in what he calls a quote silly
terrible play this is why he shows his
victims a grandfather clock a symbol of
the endless march towards death so if
humanity is bad what does that make him
he believes himself to be the bringer of
balance this is why he has such a
fascination with black widow spiders
we'll see several of his victims haunted
with images of them the black widow is a
solitary but powerful predator who feeds
off the weak without them lesser
creatures would overpopulate and bring
about instability so he believes himself
to be like the black widow calling
humanity to restore this balance and
bring the world away from chaos in his
twisted mind he's not a villain at all
henry's powers started off small he had
to cultivate them he started first with
animals in his front yard when his
mother sensed this evil within him henry
took matters into his own hands killing
her and his sister and falling into a
coma before he could kill his father
poor victor creel who believed these
murders to be the result of a demon was
arrested and institutionalized for their
deaths more than 30 years later nancy
and robin will sneak their way into
penhurst asylum to interview him and i
just gotta say it's awesome to have the
guy who played freddy krueger now
playing a character who is haunted in
his dreams
i have followed her
only to find myself
in a nightmare far worse also bonus
points if you caught the freddy krueger
cutouts in the video shop with no
parents and nowhere to go young henry
found himself under the care of dr
brenner and when it was discovered he
couldn't be controlled was implanted
with a sort of chip called sataria named
after a form of psychiatric treatment
for those suffering from mental distress
for henry ceteria stifled his powers
allowing brenner to control him
essentially making him what he calls his
slave so for years henry creel was
prevented from carrying out any violent
plans that's why there was no mysterious
murders in hawkins from about 1959 to
when eleven escapes the hawkins facility
in season one but vecna's true origins
revolve around henry creel's friendship
with eleven he befriends her at a time
when it seems everyone is against her a
sentiment which is paralleled in present
day when eleven is incessantly bullied
by roller skate extraordinaire angela
this is why you should always roll
escape to me henry or patient one as
he's also known was manipulating 11 from
the start so he could exact his revenge
on dr brenner and free himself he uses
eleven to remove his implant allowing
him to completely massacre everyone at
the facility but when eleven interrupts
him and refuses to join him on his quest
to reshape the world that's when henry
is banished to the upside down and
transforms into vechna ironically enough
it was henry's advice to hold on to a
locked memory that makes you both sad
and angry that allows eleven to
overpower him creating this gate into
the upside down where he'll soon take
control we aren't exactly sure how henry
survived this plunge into the upside
down and all these lightning bolts which
scar his body but with his powers and
the unknown physics of the upside down
anything is possible but let's dive a
little deeper into vekno's victims and
his murderous process as it might give
us clues as to what happens in volume 2.
we've already talked a bit about his
father victor creel but what about those
in present day and by present day i mean
the 1980s oh chrissy cunningham the girl
who is so sad but after meeting eddie
munson for two minutes looks at him like
i look at my dad when he picks me up
mcdonald's i'm an adult man she like the
other victims of vecna this season like
fred benson patrick mckinney and max
mayfield all share the same symptoms
headaches nausea hallucinations and
nightmares relating to trauma from their
past it's this trauma that allows vecna
to really latch into them we'll see this
one instance of vecna searching for his
next victim and hearing various
townsfolk talk about their fears and
frustrations fred's trauma was that he
was involved in a car crash where
someone was killed a crash where he was
likely the driver and he feels
responsible for that max feels guilty
over the death of her brother billy
patrick we don't know much about and
chrissy is plagued by an emotionally
abusive mother who pushes her to become
bulimic in episode 1 we see chrissy
purging and later haunted by the voice
of her mother taunting her calling her a
fat pig later the mom says she'll loosen
her cheerleader outfit because she's
gained weight there's also a scene with
a dinner table filled with a feast of
rotten food that vecna uses to taunt her
when one starts to receive these visions
from vecna they have about 24 hours
before they're killed but a week before
that they experience headaches chills
and nightmares it's never explained why
they aren't immediately murdered maybe
vecna needs time to really get into
their minds essentially weakening them
enough for him to kill them or maybe he
just wants to taunt them before they're
killed after all he does say he wanted
to hold a mirror up to his victims so
they could see themselves for the evil
people they really are but it's max
who's the only one who escapes vecna's
curse that trance-like state his victims
can't seem to snap themselves out of in
episode 4 when nancy and robin visit the
asylum they learn that music can act as
a gateway to parts of the brain that may
otherwise be shut off so when max is
thrust into the upside down under
vechna's curse they blast her with some
music which creates a tear between our
world and the upside down this could
really come into play in volume 2. but
more interesting is the fact max was
able to reach vechna's hideout without
him knowing when he finds out she's
there he's legitimately curious how she
intruded on his space in episode 7
dustin theorizes that max may have
discovered a back door into vecna's lair
this is definitely something i'm going
to keep an eye on going into volume 2.
there's also a ton of new information
regarding the upside down when nancy and
the gang travel to her house hoping to
find weapons they learn that it's
basically trapped in time november 6
1983 to be exact the date will byers
went missing and the gate between our
world and the upside down first opened
while using his compass to find eddie
dustin theorizes that the reason it goes
crazy was due to interference by an
electromagnetic field these gates
between worlds produce such a field so
it can be surmised that many such gates
may be all around hawkins and that these
gates spring up at every murder site
that's why we'll see one at the bottom
of the lake where patrick died and
eddie's trailer where chrissy met her
demise this may also have something to
do with nancy being teleported to that
empty pool where barb was killed way
back in season one so much for hashtag
justice for barb communication is also a
bit weird here in the real world dustin
can use his voice to communicate to
those on the other side but those in the
upside down can only communicate using
light and i really enjoyed the creative
way they showed this using a light
bright kind of like the christmas lights
in season one perhaps the biggest
cliffhanger from season three was what
the hell happened to hopper well we get
our answer in episode 2 when it's
revealed he survived the blast and was
picked up by the russians joyce buyers
and 11 believing hopper to be dead have
moved on with their lives that is until
joyce receives a mysterious package from
russia with a doll containing a note
that looks like it was written by my
ex-girlfriend demanding we get back
together she knows this message must
have been from someone who knows hopper
since it mentions enzo's the restaurant
she and hopper were to go to she'll team
up with karate master murray on a risky
journey to break hopper out of prison
with the help of the guy who played the
man with no name from game of thrones
while hawkins deals with its own curse
so too does hopper believing he has
cursed everyone around him in episode 4
he says of joyce
that's not because he doesn't love her
it's because the closer he gets to her
the more danger she's in and this has
happened to everyone he's loved in his
life the daughter he had with his first
wife diane died due to complications he
believed were the result of his
exposures to chemicals in vietnam he
then drowned himself in alcohol and
drugs to numb the pain and it seems
everyone who comes close to him suffers
a tragic fate see i was wrong this whole
time
i wasn't cursed
i am the curse the last we see of hopper
in this volume is him being reunited
with joyce after he defeated the
demogorgon we saw the russians capture
in the season 3 post credit scene but
just how will these guys escape the
prison and get back to hawkins their
plane is trashed and they're in the
middle of soviet russia my best guess
has something to do with the keys these
giant machines we saw the russians
create in season 3 which open gates to
the upside down if hopper and the gang
can find a way into the upside down
perhaps there's a gate that can take
them directly to hawkins season 4 also
ups the ante with the u.s government's
relentless pursuit of 11 who they
believe to be the cause not the solution
to all these mysterious occurrences in
hawkins they're led by lieutenant
colonel jack sullivan who will do
anything including torture and murder to
find her whereabouts on the other side
is dr brenner and sam owens who believe
11 is the solution just a fun fact that
sam is from ruth nevada and ruth means
friendship in hebrew it's ironic then
that sam betrays eleven in a sort of
necessary evil to get her powers back if
vecna is to be stopped eleven will need
to face her past and confront her
biggest trauma this is done in a tank
called nina which coincidentally
originates from babylonian meaning
enclosure of fish nina also means little
girl in spanish as dr brenner tells 11
nina is also a reference to a 1786 opera
in which a woman's lover is killed in a
duel so she buries this painful memory
and shows up at a train station every
day thinking he'll return to her 11 will
need to unbury her own painful memory
even if it means discovering something
about herself she might not like only by
facing all of ourselves the good and the
bad
can we become whole luckily this whole
red herring that she might have been the
one to massacre everyone at the lab was
exactly that however living with the
fact she was involved in creating vechna
will have to be something explored in
the next volume also completely off
topic can we just take a moment to
acknowledge how this unnamed secret
agent dude took down like five
professional special forces all by
himself just using a pistol he the real
mvp i will
remember you
there's also a lot of shipping going on
this season on twitter but i'm here to
say y'all sleeping on argyle in eden as
we have about a month until the final
two episodes premiere the finale being a
whopping two and a half hours there are
a bunch of theories and predictions i'd
like to make if you're watching this
video after the entire series has ended
feel free to turn the video off here as
to not find out everything i say here is
wrong one of the biggest indicators for
predicting endings revolves around
character arc a great example of this is
eddie munson my personal new favorite
addition to the show his character
starts off as a self-described coward
running away when chrissy is murdered
there is no shame in running
don't try to be heroes i didn't know
what to do so i i
i ran away so uh i did the thing that i
do now apparently
i ran
the writers are setting eddie up to
redeem himself by doing something very
heroic this echoes with max's arc as
well who feels guilt for not being
heroic enough to help her brother expect
these two to face their fears and
complete their respective arcs steve
harrington and robin buckley have their
own character journeys which revolve
around love steve goes on so many dates
but wants to find the right woman while
robin has found the right woman but
can't seem to go on a date steve needs
to realize that his perfect girl is
right in front of him nancy who actually
risks her life to save him an act which
eddie calls
unambiguous sign of true love
as these cynical eyes
have ever seen i guess sorry jonathan
with nancy currently in the upside down
it looks like steve will return the
favor and come looking for her robin
will hopefully find the strength on her
journey to ask vicki out that girl she's
been crushing on in band but hasn't had
the courage to ask out for fear of being
outed and this leads to one of the
biggest arcs of all elevens which
revolves around acceptance and loving
yourself for who you really are lucas
will and eleven all share some form of
this arc at the beginning of the season
eleven struggles with her own identity
not fitting it at school and the loss of
her powers i am different
i do not belong she feels she needs to
belong and even lies to her boyfriend
about who her friends are something will
calls her out on she even goes so far as
to call herself a monster what if i'm
not good
what if i'm the monster this points to
her arc ending in one of acceptance
where she embraces who she really is and
this acceptance will give her the
strength to defeat vechna will also has
a similar arc with his version being one
of accepting his own sexuality it's
clear he has a thing for guys turning
down ftse with a girl from school and
obviously pining for his best friend
mike for him to really grow he'll need
to be honest with himself and to mike
and this might involve finally divulging
that painting he did that he's been
hiding since episode 1. please don't be
a nude lucas also had an acceptance arc
but that one is pretty much completed he
wanted to fit in with the popular kids
at school but what he really needed was
to realize popularity means nothing when
contrasted with the friendship of your
true friends also my big mic prediction
is that he'll tell eleven he loves her
something she chastised him for not
doing in any of his letters from mike
from mike from my from
volume two will undoubtedly have mike
and the gang along with susie following
the coordinates to 11 in nevada now i
looked up the coordinates myself and
they lead to a storage building in
nevada so they're basically off to that
secret nina facility but guess who's
also making their way there sullivan and
the us government remember he likely got
11's location from torturing this guy
named wallace so expect a big showdown
there with 11 saving the day my guess is
that this big finale will take place in
hawkins and not this nevada lab so i
think after the us government showdown
we head back there where 11 will be
reunited with joyce and hopper now this
is mainly a gut feeling because there's
only one quick sentence of dialogue that
kind of backs it up but i think hopper
is going to die for good okay okay maybe
like a 20 chance take a listen to this
line maybe i can still help l
even if it's the last thing i do this is
either foreshadowing him that he'll
sacrifice himself to save her thus
ending his curse or maybe it's just a
red herring vechna is also getting more
powerful so i wonder if his invasion
will start in the final episodes i could
totally see a ton of gates and monsters
unleashed on the world or in hawkins
with 11 in the gang having to come
together to stop vecna for good now i'm
all out of eggos and i do have a dnd
party to get to tonight so thank you for
giving this video a watch be sure to
like and let me know what you thought
about this first volume of season four
i'll be covering the next one in about a
month's time so make sure you're
subscribed for that you can also follow
me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
you